our wonderful producers have put this
together
what is ben shapiro let's see what are
people asking
known for um debate
speaking quickly it could be any of
these
what is ben shapiro
net worth um yes yes
well a lady never tells what is
ben shapiro saying well you have to slow
me down to 0.75 to truly understand
what i'm saying but i do sound somewhat
drunk
what is ben shapiro
favorite movie oh that's a nice question
i like that one so
um let's see the lives of others lord of
the rings amadeus
the batman trilogy all the king's men
those are
the top five although two of those are
trilogies what is
ben shapiro's favorite song
hmm good question fantasia on a theme by
thomas thomas by rafa von williams
[Music]
[Applause]
but if we're talking about like pop
songs uh i've got you under my skin
it's a sinatra with nelson riddle what
is
ben shapiro up to no good
no good okay here we go alrighty next
we have ken ben shapiro sing
yeah it's it's not like the most amazing
thing but i can sing a little bit i do
take requests i mean on all access this
is one of the reasons people subscribe
to all access to hear me do so many
things
and i do sing i also do singing
impersonations
so i've i've done john kerry john cower
reporting for climate duty
singing broadway musicals um
you know ken ben shapiro grow a beard
okay
so little known fact i actually grow a
beard super fast
fabiola knows this right because every
morning i shave like at night and by the
morning
i have to shave again like the stubble
comes in like
super fast now i've never grown out a
full beard because then i have to come
in and do the show
but every year i consider growing a
beard i feel like
at that point i'm just a rabbi like but
pretty much at that point
that's all i can be can ben shapiro
act no i mean the clear answer on that
one is absolutely not we have tried this
in multiple different situations
and we've tried this for a variety of
different little sketches that we do
i have like one face and i can do the
one face
and pretty much that's the whole thing
that's that's that's all
although i have been told that sometimes
i'm able to muster enthusiasm when i
feel done so that that maybe i think
can ben shapiro throw a pitch
so yes uh i'm not gonna say that i have
the the best arm in the world
because i don't when i was a kid uh i i
was a pretty good
baseball player i can hit uh i'm
actually a pretty good contact hitter
i can i can hit from either side of the
plate and i have 2010 vision and pretty
good reflexes so when we go to the
batting cages i hit pretty easily in the
80 mile per hour cage
can ben shapiro
swim thanks milo yes i can swim actually
when i was in elementary school i won
some swimming competitions
can ben shapiro drink can i drink
i mean i can i don't really like
drinking very much
you know when we started the daily water
it was a tiny company i'm talking like
seven employees in
my partner jeremy boring's pool house
and what we realized really quickly
is that in order to create buzz in order
to attract new customers we really had
to know our marketing we really had to
know
our data if you're starting a business
you need to do the same thing
every company strives to have unique
values and a long lasting impact it's
time to position your company as an
industry leader
create buzz attract new customers
generate consistent revenue and giant
partners can help you do
all of that stuff they are america's
number one data-driven marketing agency
giant partners operates in the business
to business space they offer a variety
of business marketing solutions
everything from database marketing to
brand development web design seo lead
generation
digital marketing services as well as ad
placement that's just to name a few of
the things that they do
whether you own a small family business
or handle millions in revenue every year
giant partners can help you get to the
next level their marketing strategies
are research driven they are equipped
with 20 years of data experience
don't take my word for it their largest
customers include bmw nationwide ohio
state university
3m and ethan allen so head over to
giantpartners.com
get your business set up today
is ben shapiro
married yeah of course married almost 13
years at this point got three
great kids see is ben shapiro
a genius so my dad once told me
something
about genius that i think is really
important which is that there will
always be somebody who is smarter than
you are
and what he suggested is that he didn't
believe that there were really
geniuses as in people who were like
overall really smart he said people have
a genius 4a thing
and i think that's kind of half true
there are certainly people who are
geniuses i mean i know people who are
polymaths people who have super high iqs
but the point that he was making which
is more important is right which is that
just because you happen to be really
smart does not mean that you are a
genius at everything
right just because you happen to be
really good at one thing does not mean
that you know a damn thing about another
thing
and one of the things in politics that
tends to happen is that the best and the
brightest the new ruling class
they tend to think that if they are high
iq this means they know their
all there is to know about all of the
things people who want to centralize
power and government tend to think
because i am smart
and because i'm on a raw level smarter
than all those other american dollars i
get to control
all aspects of their life but here is
the thing diffuse information
across a wide variety of human beings
will always in some be greater than any
amounts of information available to one
human being and so anybody who claims
that genius matters it really like
genius only matters if it is channeled
toward a particular purpose or it's in a
particular field
but the question is not whether you have
a high iq the question is to what use
you put the raw material when i was in
junior high
i went to a magnet school and they gave
a an iq test to get into the magnet
school
and there were people who had way higher
iqs
in my in my class than i did there's one
girl who had an iq that was in the 190s
uh and she was doing like college level
calculus
in what would have been in seventh grade
she was doing like full-on college level
calculus in seventh grade like genius
genius
she ended up as a gym teacher at a
midwestern college
and so the question is not what is your
raw level of iq the question is what do
you do with it as my fourth grade
teacher once said to me don't let
potential be written on your tombstone
and that's the way you should view all
the gifts that you're given in life
whether it is physical gifts or iq
or emotional intelligence that's the way
you should view your life is ben shapiro
giving away money no no is ben
shapiro libertarian so
when it comes to the role of government
i'm generally libertarian when it comes
to the role
of social structures i'm a conservative
right so i i don't think that the job of
the government is to cram down my
particular
social values i do think that you need a
rich and robust social structure that is
capable of inculcating those values into
citizenry i think that if you had to
sort of embody what i believe about
government in one quote it would be the
john adams quote
that the constitution was written for
moral and religious people and no other
because the constitution in the absence
of a moral and religious people that
people would just rush through the
boundaries of the constitution like a
whale through a net
is ben shapiro a gamer
uh no uh so i don't know anything about
video games i've spent no time on video
games people have been trying to get me
into it but i have three children
okay so this is the thing people without
kids have lots of time
once you have kids you have no time for
anything for the rest of your life until
you die
okay so it is basically like you can you
can add like one thing a day
right this is what i found you can add
one thing in your schedule a day you
have to between your kids
and your job you can usually fit one
thing so maybe today it's working out
or maybe today it's going to get a
haircut but it is not two things so the
idea that you can like
spend three or four hours gaming at
night if you need sleep
and my kids will wake me up at five
o'clock in the morning no
i don't i don't have time for that is
ben shapiro
running for president in 2024 god forbid
sounds awful first of all i have to deal
with people who work in government which
sounds like garbage
second of all i have a great job i get
to tell you exactly what i think on a
daily basis
whereas candidates are in the business
of telling you what you want to hear on
a daily basis which is the precise
opposite of what i do
for a living what i've said before is
that if circumstances compelled me
to run then maybe i would think about it
at some point in the future
we have reached the end of this
particular video we'll see you here next
time